france has seen more towns and cities
announce
where and when wearing a mask will be
obligatory
in public as it aims to curb the uptick
in the uh cases of coronavirus that have
been recorded here
on from monday the city of lille in the
northern part of france
has said that wearing a mask is going to
be obligatory now in the city's
pedestrian areas
and also in the city's parks that
follows decisions for example in orleans
which has decided that if you go to the
open air market in that city you will
have to wear a mask
and in tourist hot spots such as birits
and samala they've said that within the
city
you will have to wear a mask if you are
over the age of 11
and that follows an announcement by the
french health minister
who said that that decision could be
taken locally
to limit the circulation of covid19 the
prefectures can now by decree
extend the obligation to wear a mask to
open public places
this decision can be made locally
depending on the spread of the epidemic
in each territory
well france has been seeing an upsurge
in the number of positive covid19 cases
of being announced most worryingly
health experts say that that uptake
is between those aged 20 and 30 with a
54 increase now meanwhile there is work
underway to create a covid19 vaccine all
that pressure
to create one fast with many countries
saying that they will have
something that they can roll at by the
end of 2020
but the eu is actually warning that even
if there is a kobit 19 vaccine that is
ready
there are many hurdles to face because
its
members face an issue with a lack of
certain certain gear that
is needed to roll out
that vaccine that includes a lack of
syringes
a lack of masks and also a lack
of wipes coveted 19 vaccines once
developed may come without syringes and
other items
and there could be shortages of those
member states were asked to comment on
their preparedness
regarding the availability of supplies
for immunization
for example syringes alcohol wipes ppe
now all of this comes as the latest
figures show that across
europe more than 210 000 people
are said to have died with their deaths
being linked to covet 19.
you